[Music] what do you know about this movie uh
Steven Lang is in it and that's it do you know
who Steven Lang is yeah I do can you name a very
famous film he was in are you gonna quiz me all
movie or how's this gonna go just just this
one question is all you get competition time
who can hold their breath for longer three two
1 okay don't breathe PGE we're watching don't
breathe it's a horror movie and uh I just won
that competition you did you got buried by me
you win every competition we play I don't know
if that's true it's true but I did win this one
and it's because I used to hold my breath in
tunnels every single time you try to make it
do that too yeah what's up with that hands up
eyes closed holding the breath making a wish how
you doing Happy 2024 I'm doing well how are you
I'm doing well same me still in this posture you
know who else is doing well who you weren't even
going to try to take a guess I was about to the
rejects the re citizens of the reject happy yall
exactly if you are here with us we're so grateful
please don't forget like comment subscribe if
I was ter say ring that Bell whoa Purge you're
finally catching along you want to be super sexy
reject then go ahead over to our patreon sync up
with your own copy Greg and John exclusively do
watch alongs and things I would tell you exactly
what it said if Greg made this in a font that I
could read in any way shape or form that was even
close legible thank you so much to prepper for
helping us edit down this video are you ready to
do this I'm ready to hold my breath I'll film
the whole time the whole time okay let's do
[Music] it I hate that sound it's like nails on a
chalkboard yeah is that on purpose it's to set the
mood for what we're in for New Year same city way
bigger houses on the right than the left what is
the financial disparity here I know feel there's
a social commentary they're they're trying to tell
us here about the the right side and the left side
here but it's like when you drive down Beverly
Hills and it's LA and Beverly Hills and half the
road's paved and half of it is not true this is
all cracks say crack again crack dragging a dead
body oh that's not a crack that's a blood
trail I see I see oh that's a quite the [Music]
reveal I think she wins the don't breathe contest
Jesus 19 18 Roy those are very slow
seconds yo kill that already that's
funny we heard 2019 I thought
they were saying the year 2019 10
N I told you this was going to be fancy
oh what movie is she in I don't know but
that's dlan Reet I know one 13 reasons
why the guy on the left yep okay so this
is a a robbery oh I feel like they could have
gotten some nicer shoes in there now I know
her what oh God giving the house a
new paint job so it must be personal
cuz they're not just taking
things okay let's get out of
here interesting that they wanted to set the
alarm off yeah cuz they could have got away
clean there yeah it's either personal or they're
just in it for the thrill no must be personal
otherwise you're not peeing and lying in the
bed yeah yeah I don't know if I'm right but no
no I mean you you make a very ladybug you make a
very valid point do you make a wish on a ladybug
or no I don't make a wish usually but I usually
like keeping them I just think they're so cool
we keep hitting houses like today's Rocky and
bye-bye Detroit and Alla California well okay
keep hitting houses so maybe not personal
everyone has wronged them you're going away
rock yeah as soon as I can when are you coming
back never he loves her what everyone else is
gone I got my dad here so he's doing it for
the money he's got to help his dad dad you're
home huh a slight change in
music that was interesting there
too so is his dad in real estate or why does he
have all of the home security Ah that's why they
made it look like it was a Breakin through the
window cuz they don't want anybody know they Ed
the key cuz his dad would get in trouble yep yo
this is it Manus my 40% Rolex in there bro what
do you think I'm going to put it up on a s be
yeah know how much people on the street pay for
a hot relics Black Market you want money then
steal money [__] bro his money symbol tattoo
is so aggressive you know what I like money
it's almost as subtle as the damaged Joker
no family just him in the house some pry girl
few years ago I over this guy's daughter Jesus
daughter dies and this pry Rich ass family pays
him off gives him a big ass sediment sediment me
your honor his breathing is freaking me out
hey always seems like he's out of breath do
you think the money's in the house I don't know
let's go find out guys no we don't do cash that
amount brings a serious cop presence I'll do
an investigation my dad could get in trouble
need [__] out man if we do this right we
never have to do it again ooh she's maybe
he doesn't need the money though because he
does seem like the preppy boy compared to the
other two we're not doing this one seriously
maybe he knows the girl who got killed or
something they put a lot of red under her nose
I wonder if this is a drug thing you need to get
out of here please do this for me why did
they sh like that yeah it's hard to read
interesting oh and some investigative work
they blur a lot in this movie interesting go
for vetan just six figure settlement oh we're in
Gross Point gross Point's nice you done Diddy be
a doll and get your mother a large four cheese
from Tony's so Trevor's is living here now oh it
was the Gross Point person that hit them don't
be a [__] roxan is just a few months till he
can find a new job roxan don't be a [__] Rock
in you have no money in here you pay for it then
I know you're making money got to wonder why she
would want to get out of there and move to LA such
a stable home that's what this rock sand did I'm
her I want to go to the beach yeah well it's not
summer monkey head I want to be a surfer there's
no Surfer in Michigan some things you can't change
baby no matter how unfair they are what a bummer
agreed babe he's like I did my research let's do
it California what do you say you and I move there
together would you like that both their eyes are
huge what's the horror movie with Justin long
and the it's the person mother downstairs not
jeepers creep no no no recently oh um oh oh last
year Barbarian oh uh that street looks like the
Barbarian street is that a new tattoo yeah I got
it last night is it a ladybug oh when my dad left
my mom started drinking and she told me that my
dad's leaving was all my fault that's nice blam
everything on your kids and I missed them a lot
so I'd cry she got so fed up with the crying that
she would lock me in the trunk of her car good
parenting yeah sounds like a wonderful mother a
little hole in the trunk and one time a ladybug
flew in kept me company when I reach California
I'm going to color this tat and that's the last
time I will mark my body if we get this money I'm
going away with you guys I know you will there'll
be a family yeah but this guy's going to mess it
all up I was going to say he does seem like
the the Wild Card guys a shot and hasn't left
his house in like 5 days so we do it with him
in the house I'll get a Chlor bomb jeez Purge
Purge that no that freaked me too no that really
got me that was not a fake reaction I promise you
guys I how could that have been fake I mean you
just I literally not to be asked but you just look
like a little [__] thank you appreciate
it I did I did so I guess that was a fair
comment sorry that's saying I didn't think it was
F fake cuz you really wait is he blind he's lost
his sight in Iraq or something it's kind of up to
rob a blind guy isn't it just cuz he's blind don't
mean he's insane bro oh when I go see horror
films in theaters which is very rare I'm sorry
hoodie over my head that was so mean of me I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's all good you are forgiven
I'm very I'm very I I I listen there's a little
bee in all of us there's a little be in all of
us cool shot very cool I can't really
see anything but very cool yeah but I
I loved that yeah no no it was very cool
though I mean anything it's too a.m. he's
sleeping take care of that dog first yeah
I love when you can just see the faces or
Silhouettes some could say I love the darkness
ah you think darkness is your ally born in it
raised by it you merely adopted the
dark oh man I really like this girl
oh imagine that's going to put it I'm
sure they're just going to put it to
sleep I don't think I don't think they're
going to hurt it just going to put it to
sleep I'm under the assumption they think
this is a 5 minute job there's four locks
you got the other keys well I only have
the one why wouldn't he give backup keys
to the security company cuz the money's
in there and the paranoid doesn't trust
nobody no it's it's a setup why wouldn't he give
backup keys to the security company that's the
question oh no I'm just worried cuz a dog
jump scare got me really bad so I'm like
I'm like feel self-conscious I'm sorry no no
no no no I'm not even worried about that I'm
just like I get it really bad so I'm like
really you'll be okay I'm probably not you
will any thoughts right now on why it's
called Don't breathe I feel like they're
about to get kidnapped well I definitely feel
like they're walking into some kind of I think
he didn't give backup keys because he keeps
people in here this is some kind I mean yeah
we saw at the beginning he was dragging a
body so well we saw a body being dragged
right this gu is messing up oh my God oh
my God not the fingers not the fingers oh
oh no no no and you are making a lot of noise
what about that window there's no bars on it I
can fit in there oh no I feel like they're
going into the home of like a future older
M or Kevin McAllister it's just a home full
of traps I think that this is like a black
phone situation oh oh oh oh the hands coming
in and us not knowing what's on the other side
yeah no it's your your imagination's just
playing like what is on the other side side
uhoh you don't get I suddenly I hate this
movie it's definitely already very suspenseful
no honestly I'm having a hard time
breathing yeah no no no no no Purge Purge
okay we're like 20 minutes in whoa that was
close no no no no no no no do not settle
in yet do not sett I mean she's about to get
grabbed something something five four three two
one five four three going to have
a bunch of five second [Music]
countdowns you're just preparing yourself yeah
just why is it upside down uh well they said
his daughter right was yeah why was it upside
down cuz she's in a grave somewh I don't know
she must have got it by now she's fine yeah I
can really give a what you say that's my [__]
in there of course I give a all I want to be is
somebody's [__] be a good friend and stay in
the [__] [__] friends of we got a little
triangle going on here shoes off shoes off well
I think they want to avoid making noise side
but I just also like that can't be the right
choice I mean they've made noise already they
broke a window the alarm was going off yeah
he knows they're in the house no doubt he
does what is their intention with him
I mean they want to steal cash but no
intention with him like they're just
hoping he doesn't wake up and if he
does they're goingon to Chlor form him
locked that's where they he's keeping
people oh there's got to be some body or
hearts or so who knows what he's done in
there this is giving dmer even Freddy Krueger
had a boiler room you know I don't think I've
ever seen Friday the 13th it's is that
what that movie is Freddy Krueger's
Nightmare and El Street you know what I
don't think I've ever seen Nightmare on
El Street Friday the 13th is Jason okay
I haven't seen either I don't think I've
only seen Halloween I'm only recently into
horror films and I'm loving them yeah I
think you'd like those is it a gun that's
taped under I think it's just so hard to
see oh is he asleep I don't know I
doubt it very obviously not asleep
just I so wow okay you're right he's [Music]
not what is it he's drugging
is okay is it possible he's not the only
one in the house maybe I don't yeah darn
guy's gassed out he's he's he's out he's
in Sleeping Beauty more it's fine guys
that's why it's called Don't breathe
think you can grack it [Applause] open
maybe he's keeping like Monsters down there
or something like maybe they shouldn't come
outus I thought he was the bad guy but I don't
know I mean I think these are the I mean even
though we sympathize with them they're still
they're stealing but for sure I'm just thinking
I thought he was keeping people in his basement
because that's true I guess evil they're all
antagonists but maybe he's not I'm going to pop
that [__] like again do you have any idea we
bringing a gun to a Burg he means he gives me a
better chance to defend myself Alex we mean you
just gave this guy the legal right to shoot us
yep let's go no no no no I think we should stay
we have to leave this is not good yes get
out logicality that's a different movie oh
silencer
oh no so out good oh no he's not going to be
able to leave oh no what's in there no no no
no no no no no hey man just chill all right I
I I was wasted and and I I wandered in so that
that was my bet all right so I'm just going
to I'm just going to leave okay what was that
oh it's lock oh don't I know what's
in there and I ain't leaving without
it take one single step all right uh dude is
built like a train s don't you move Pass Me
Jesus dude keep doing what you
were doing go run away stop who
oh
[__] guess there's the old saying make him
think you're weak when you're strong how many
of you are there how many I'm by myself
just me man all right just me just let me
go oh no oh no don't try to help him do not
oh he's so going to shoot him okay I swe to go
snikes oh this dude is crazy I mean technically
that is someone's trespassing on your property
but I mean that was the the what that was the
crazy route and the guy had a gun at him but
still it's like how did he get out of the gas
room upstairs where is Dylan man's character
and what's downstairs in regards to the
gas question you asked I would assume he
heard him in there and he was just holding his
breath knowing that that went off it's it oh
no oh you should have oh my God God
damn it Dylan that's a different
movie
Purge
oh you are now locked in sir you should
have stayed out stay out the sequel to get
out oh dear Lord oh I would not want
to be locked in a house with that
man now I understand why it's called Don't
breathe I can't believe he didn't leave
I mean he's in love Yeah but he told her
to come with him she's going to text
for help do not text him right now his
phone's going to go off all the guys
in there yeah no no yeah he will hear
that oh smart he put it on
vibrate he's going to be
like yes I can pursue her now
man
right is now a good time for like I told you so
feel like Dylan should say that to her I would
wait till you get out of the house but and you
can say that a bunch of times but he definitely
owes her a lot of those we always see people
in movies do this to keep themselves quiet do
you think that helps it seems to be right now oh
no oh well think they found the money what's the
code wow it says right on there 2978
what do you think that date means so
February 9th 1978 what happened I don't
know because we saw in that video that
his daughter I it was what like 1998 or
something so that's can't be his daughter's
birthday there's still got to be something
downstairs the lock went to downstairs not
to this room that had the money in
it I'm telling you there's bodies in
that downstairs room that there was no
money in there cuz we know the money's
right but maybe he was trying to protect the
world from something as opposed to keeping
something in there I don't know may we
should call the cops before he do this
come I'm actually in agreement
with him I'd rather go to jail me
too how are you going to make it out want
more than 300 Grand in that there got to
be about a million dollars okay let's get
out of here how he boarded up everything he
locked the doors the storm doors both from the
inside that can be way on no no o o o o o no
no this actress is awesome she is but I also think
he's awesome too Steph I know he's
awesome too I just KN I knew him and
her remember when the guy money
said move this way or whatever I
feel like Steven Lang knows there more
than one person in the house yeah he's
very intuitive also who know who knows
how visually impaired he is no no no
jeez oh my God is that the mirror
[Music]
Jesus I didn't know a vibrating phone could
get on me like that is that mone's phone or
is that one of their phones I don't know whose
phone that was I know they both should have a
phone yeah this movie is like the longer extended
scarier version of in Matilda when they went into
Miss trunchbull's house and they were trying
to escape Miss honey and Matilda I don't know
if you remember that I do I think downstairs
is the chokey well the chokey was at school
Roxy just saying was in Miss trench's office
right this that was my joke no something's up
down here no no no no no remember this was
locked y'all whatever's down here is worse
they're like I just want to get away from
this guy I don't care where we have to go
[__] night I wonder how much of a challenge
this was for the actors too cuz the how this is
lit it had to be brighter and they did oh
and they just imp yeah cuz otherwise you're
so dangerous right it's like guys
we keep hitting things can't see oh
no problem is when you lose one sense you gain a
lot in the others what do you think he's smelling
perfume that could POS be a POS he might walk
them downstairs oh the shoes ooh he's going to
find two pairs uh-oh oh no damn uhoh okay so I
got two more people here no not two more I think
that one of these remember CU didn't Dylan grab
his own shoes oh that's right that's right think
one at least one that's a good point cuz one
of those is Money shoes I was to check there's
no money in there oh [__] oh no oh no oh now
I'm on the hunt they took my money am I well now
he should call the cops but he just killed
somebody but it was in his own house I just
say I never want harm T anyone but I'm not I'm
not even rooting for these guys like they went
into this guy's house and stole from him yeah
completely the the thing that's going to change
our minds as an audience is if what's down here
then we stop rooting for him depending on what is
what does he what atrocities has he committed even
though again we saw a little glimpse of it at the
beginning Bell just wrong oh no oh Andrew what the
hell was that what here right
now come on he can't help her
out oh I want to see what's
on that note is that his
daughter we can leave right now
innocent of oh that's the one who
was accused of his daughter oh she's
the one who killed his daughter oh we
have to get her out of here oh my
God you can get her out once you
leave it's
safe oh my God move move are
you guys nuts Stop Standing
the movie's called Don't breathe not don't
move but I'm telling you I think that she might
not be she might be a menace to Society it might
not be him oh the backup remember the backups
that he wouldn't leave with the security yep
no she's evil I don't know something's wrong you
don't trust her you don't trust no I don't I don't
oh no he's going to meet them out on the other
end oh no oh no oh no they are making so much
noise he's going to be right there Purge Purge
no no what's wrong it's locked don't you have the
keys Dy show me come on oh I like actually have
to close my eyes I feel sick I'll
just I'll I'll commentary what's
happening no no he's right there he's right
there ah he's going to be on the other side
oh
jeez oh she was help what oh she got shot oh no
[Music] Jesus this dude has said like like three
lines all moving and I'm beyond terrified of him
what were the three lines or whatever he said like
how many of you are there or something whatever it
was it must have just been an accident that
that was it oh my God he's about to realize
that he killed the girl this is the time
to run out right now or like bum rush him
or something I don't know if you're going
to bum rush him he's built like a tank I
know but if I'm them you like you got to
try to run out and if not you got to try
to get the gun something can't just
sit there no no for sure for sure no
no also I don't know about the term I just
used now that I'm thinking about it is that
a PC term which term P Rush it's fine it's
turning getting rid of the electricity whose
hands have the keys oh he's locking it oh oh he's
breaking these keys they nice locked on the front
door oh broke it he shoved that thing
in there so they couldn't use it
yeah oh and he shot the phone
so they don't have a flashlight
yeah the sound design is wickedly insane
they've got to take him [Music] out do you
think there's anybody else
down here I I don't think
so do you think that was the body he
was dragging though at the beginning
was that girl or was that someone
else that's what I'm curious about
I'm not sure cuz it would looked like
blood that was being right she seemed
unharmed all we know is this newspaper article
they assumed that this was the woman that killed
his daughter his daughter but I don't know
maybe this was his other daughter and he was
trying to keep her safe and the body was
the person who shot the like I'm letting
my mind wander right right maybe he's actually
actually going to speak some lines and let us S
no no no this is shot so scary oh my God no no
she's going to walk right into him I would not
be moving right now stop moving I know I told
you to move before but stop moving no no oh do
not she almost literally go deaf from that
too in real life that got me that got me
good
oh oh my God that is so
scary did she just help him with that I don't
think think so cuz it looks like she hasn't
moved rocky rocky rocky Roy let's go let's
go way way but what but why are we now just
talking free willly come on come on no no
no what's up there oh did he lock it no I
don't I don't know is he did he get up there I
feel like he would know every I mean if there's
what's up there something something else got
out run oh it's a dog cuz remember that it was
only supposed to keep him sleep like Y what
they assumed was a 10 15 minute job go to the
door what do you do with the dog I don't know
I just don't like animals getting harmed on
film and TV I feel like he went outside oh
no he's going to hit it with the Crowbar oh
no oh I hate animals getting harmed in movies and
TV there's a website that tells you that
oh when it happens in what movies yeah
no oh they lost the keys oh they're going to
go in the gas room maybe that's the Dodger's
bedroom okay everything's boarded or B yeah and
it's like why what are you doing I'm pressing the
panic button if I manage to get in range the
system will call 911 and the police will wait
we can't go to jail yes go to jail okay this is
robbery versus kidnapping and murder the police
won't care about us but then we wouldn't keep
the money are you an idiot Rocky you you'll keep
your lives you don't get to keep the money if
you're dead honey she's like I'll take the risk
go hit the button don't listen to her
seriously he's listened to her too many
times she's going to find
something something crazy up
here oh oh ah ah he's dead how would you
survive that oh no oh no well even if you
survived that I don't know about
this part cuz now he's outside the
house but he's about to be back inside
the house yet again that would really
hurt oh no this is not good oh no oh no
no oh and that's making the cracking noise
he's going to hear that maybe he falls right
on him though he's got to be alive because
otherwise the movie is not as entertaining
I get it Jail's no fun but like better than
the alternative oh wow is the dog going
in there oh my God smart dog Jesus oh
my God damn that is a very intuitive I
do not want to see what happens right
now
go oh boo you up hey boo you up nope don't do
that it's going to get shot up right now oh my God
no jeez dude these bullet sound designs
are so jump scary did he hit it hit the
button hit the button no no where's
the dog I wonder if he disabled the
alarm did he get him I don't
know no I think he got him I
don't think so I think he's holding himself from
the oh wait that's her oh no different
person I think it's where she fell out
of if they hold their breath we have to that's I
I've been doing it the whole movie
no no he breathes oh yeah he heard
that this dude is Relentless oh no
oh
ah oh my God wo wo the noise
yeah
y he almost had the [Music] gun
reach oh oh oh he disabled
that oh no I actually like his character oh
God I think that answered your question [__]
where did he just hit him I couldn't tell but
I think he's in the same place as money
okay but at this point does Steven Lang
think he's gotten everybody he did
hear him say he did hear him say say
her name out right so I don't know he's
intutive I think he knows yeah I think so
too again because of the lighting was hard did she
fall hard on yeah I think she went down a shoot
okay just again it just broke her legs there's
no way he locked that off did he oh my God I hit
oh it's just naturally locked oh cuz it's it's
screw bolted the fingers through the whatever
damn
oh God how is she going to survive this remember
when we saw Dy manetti next to a body it seemed
like was there another body there that could
have been money but I don't know I think it was
her oh crap Jesus does nobody survive
in this movie I don't know but he felt
to see that she was a woman just
now did he put her to sleep or
did he permanently put her to sleep oh
maybe he ties her up downstairs you're
thinking okay yeah okay but the thing about Dylan
manetti's character is that he has the keys so his
dad if he ever looks he'll see those keys for this
place are gone right well I thought he said that
the back didn't he say the backup keys that he
kept them that Stephen Lang kept them yeah but
he still had one key and they said why would
he only give one key not the other backup keys
right oh oh poor thing damn he bruised her up I
understand you she killed her daughter I wanted
her to pay I'm not sure that's what happened you
understand nothing only a parent can know the oh
bond between a father and his child uhoh I hate
torture she should have gone to prison but rich
girls don't go to jail okay none of this is
going to bring your daughter back that's not
really true Cindy took my child away from me
so he's trying to make a new daughter it's only
fair that she give me a new one oh he impregnated
her uhoh that's why he was so sad when she died
pregnant with my baby oh you killed them both
well they would be alive if you hadn't broken
into my home uh is this going to be the new yeah
of course oh I guess that's why you didn't kill
her you have to be held accountable yeah that
is such an crazy thing like to do that to the
person oh my God is he alive I think now I
know what uh wait wait wait who is this oh
my god oh cuz there was another body oh he put
it in a different body yeah but what is that
body I can't believe he's still alive
cuz he didn't get no no no I know but
just from yeah that was really cool shot
he's seriously so freaking strong it's
like those are little oh the dog no
don't hurt the dog no he's got it I
know I know okay okay thank you
I'm good with that that works for
[Music] me tar cement oh puts it in the floor
oh so he has to know that he needs to get
out of the house in order to help her right
like he's not going to go downstairs and try
to help her he wouldn't be a movie character
if he didn't go downstairs right yeah but I'm
a little worried cuz the alarm's going to go
off right and then he's going to hear
the alarm go off what are you doing oh
Lordy I never forced myself on her oh I promised
I would set her free just as
soon as she gave me a child
now she's gone but I'm done
waiting no no no what are you going to do
wait so he's going to inseminate
her you can't do this to me oh okay I understand
well okay so he's going to inseminate her right
yeah this is such an insane 9 months
and I will give you your life back
oh my [Music] god oh oh Dylan's man's
character went downstairs what who H
ho but he hasn't killed him yet I'm super nervous
right now you got to kill the guy also dude this
guy is so tough like he smashed him in the
hand earlier and that didn't phase him at
all
oh guys get out of the house oh he's going
to do it anyway oh oh o that was is Rocky
Rocky it's over come on it's not over o o
or he can get out of this or something oh
no oh oh he hits the alarm going to rot
in prison for what you've done we can't
involve the cops now if we steal a million
in cash and then leave the cops here he'll
tell them about us you got what you
came for I'll take it get out of my
house he needs us to take the money it's
one or the other but if you choose with
you there's a little urgency here that
I feel like you guys aren't keeping up
with I think he's coming for them
I don't know oh no what's out there
what's out there I know but he got out for sure he
did oh no oh no they're about to
die three two one dead dead dead
yeah he went out the other way oh
I don't think he survived this one
no oh did she leave the bag or did
she take it no she left it you think
it's on her back yeah it's on her back
maybe it saves her life no he's coming
for her oh no no no no no don't turn
back oh my God you're worthless out
here ah the
dog why did she say he's worthless out
here I mean he knows that house inside
and out even without his being
able to see going to be able to
jump this interesting I thought once we got out
of the house the movie was going to be over oh my
god oh she doesn't have the
money back to where we started the
dog at the at the car door oh oh my
goodness oh no no no no you're screwed
but the backpack's outside came out no
she's dead I feel it oh good
call what do you feel what do
you what do you do drive or
what she has no keys does money have
the keys cuz money was the drive
right what do you do call the
cops now I don't know I don't
know I wonder if Steven Lang's
character just like walks up and
grabs the bag I mean can what's she
going to do what does she have back
there oh she's going to trap the dog in
there she going to close the trunk
on it or go cuz remember she used
to get stuck in the trunk or locked
in the trunk yeah oh no oh no oh my
God that one tough
dog I know he's going to be
there somehow I mean the dog
has made a lot of noise oh no hate it no no no
no oh wow did he bring her back inside this
a Non-Stop roller coaster ride this film oh
this is the body we saw him dragging oh
from the beginning yes it is wow she's
actually dragging her back towards the house
wow interesting that they chose to show that
nonlinear storytelling I like that what's
your prediction I I mean he said he would
let her live or have her life after 9 months
oh ladybug make a wish but is your prediction
that she gets out right now or no no what's
your prediction oh I maybe she's going to
hit the alarm there there's the prediction I
guess yeah she chooses she doesn't choose the
money yeah finally see she sees the
light
oh
ooh ooh those are not replaceable
what is she going to tell the cops
oh how is this dude still
alive that's a metal crowbar I'm scared right now
though I think in her mind at that point prison
was better than nine months trapped in their
uh right but now he's dead is he I don't know
maybe the cops shoot her right now oh the cops
are there what is she going to do they see
her do you think they saw her or no I don't think
[Music] so and credits so she did get it both ways
oh now she's taking her sister to California
you and me at the beach I can imagine that's
a lot of ptst for the rest of her life last night
two burglars broke into his home and attempted to
Rob and brutally attack him doctors say he is
in stable condition what no goods were reported
stolen by the victim what is she going to do uh
just travel to California and never look back I
mean he's not going to find her I don't think
she's capable no cuz she's upset that he's the
hero now and doesn't go to prison I don't think
she's capable cuz he Resto reported no good stolen
boy that was
tery Purge Purge Purge wow Sam Ry I should
have known fedy alare is I feel like his name
is familiar too did he do an evil dead thing or
something I also don't know that franchise I feel
like his name came up recently though wow did you
breathe the whole time holy crap that was still
not breathing what a wild wild wild watch oh my
go first of all before we get into the review if
you are watching this on Apple or Spotify if you
would not mind rating this Roxy myself and all
of us here five stars baby yeah if you don't mind
rating us please we'd really appreciate it uh that
was such an intense right I mean the film just
really just it it hit the Go Button like a like a
roller coaster ride and just did not it's like did
not let up from start to finish well at least one
once we got into the house at least it just does
not let up it's like the main like Steven Lang
this film is Relentless it's so crazy is that it
does it asks of its audience members to continue
guessing right like you don't know when we get
upstairs and we see stepen Lang for the first time
kind of sleeping and it's like wait is this like a
little old man's house that they've broken into uh
what exactly is going on here to the point where
I really like you I'm like our protagonists are
definitely our antagonists like the people that
we're following I can't stand them they're they're
doing this to him they're in the wrong right and
then when we when we find out what's actually in
the basement it was so smart of them to have us
see that lock so that the whole time in my mind I
don't believe he's the good guy but but even then
I thought maybe he was trying to protect them from
whatever like there was a monster in the basement
and he was trying to keep it from getting out I
just didn't ever this movie was always ahead of
me no for sure I mean I thought there was multiple
or a lot of bodies that he had done because I
figured too after his daughter like I mean you
can understand in a s after something like that
you you just might lose it and I thought like too
when when we saw the first body which again a cool
reveal that no that was one of the main characters
that was just nonlinear storytelling I love that
reveal too I believe it was cuz we saw like the
smear on the street too from when he was dragging
the body so um so that's why I just again like you
said the film was just ahead of us I just figured
there was multiple bodies and I just had no idea
what was going on but the reveal again then what
was going on I know we got to be careful how we
we say what was really happening with the girl
in there uh you know we had we saw the newspaper
headline that uh she was innocent of all charges
with manslaughter and then we find out what he was
truly doing I I I'm trying to word out I want to
say this I don't agree with how he was doing it
but I can understand his motivation for a child
after what had happened it was interesting that
it like I love characters that play by their own
rules and have their own set of morals right and
so while he doesn't mind uh you know putting
somebody tied up while he clearly when what he
did to money immediately for thinking that he was
being a burglar yet he says I'm I'm down here and
he goes to inseminate her because what he's not
going to do is force himself on somebody and it
was like everybody has their own moral code what
a freaking bizarre one that that is your line but
it made for what you were talking about which is
like you got your daughter taken and so you you
his logic is obviously unbelievably flawed and
Disturbed but you see what happened there you
see him be like my daughter was taken I'm owed a
daughter therefore this is how the universe will
pay me back and the fact that he continues to say
I was gonna let her go after nine months I don't
know if you had the same thought I did but I'm
thinking this poor girl would have been better off
if they had left her to she would have lived yeah
not better off right and obviously they didn't
know that but yes obviously and I don't know that
he really would have who's to say that that's what
he would have done he might have he might have uh
killed her because you know obviously she would
have known what had happened she and she could
have outed him and he clearly didn't want to
get caught otherwise he would have said that they
took the money from him you know so that's a good
point I mean yeah because if he would have the the
girl that was Aid the one who was uh guilt or not
guilty of manslaughter like yeah so she has the
kid he lets her go and then like she could have
like you said she could have outed him and then
like cuz I mean that's your kidnapping you held
a woman against her will uh for nine months so I
mean she could get amongst other things yeah yeah
for sure so um his plan like you said was flawed
and um just misguided so I'm very curious like cuz
I was thinking that in the back of my head I'm
like if you do let her go you're going to go to
prison like even if you have a kid yeah so uh but
yeah no um very unless he was planning on moving
or something you know yeah what was the my my main
the only point of confusion that I really did have
with this movie is that body that ends up with
the the big sword the the trimmers I think that
was money I don't because it didn't like I said
but he would have known that because he put M's
body somewhere no he he was taking he was dragging
mone's body and then he started hearing noise and
then I I but I just would think cuz he had he
had such awareness of where everything was the
whole time if that's where he left money's body
you're right he did have awareness of everything
especially in that house but I mean he was in an
ensuing battle with Alex is that his name Dylan
Dylan character he was in an ensuing battle when
you're in a battle like that especially too with
with his uh situation where he was uh you know
uh imp impaired uh with his eyes I mean visually
impaired thank you he was impaired with his
eyes visually impaired thank you uh where he was
visually impaired I mean it's understandable in a
situation like that and the body was like within a
foot or so of Alex so it's understandably so that
he might think that that was who he hit the whole
thing is understandably so except for the fact
that they do paint him as Daredevil so if he's
Daredevil you know where you put the body but I
get but I get where you're I of course I would
have not known but they made him into this like
like all knowing even when downstairs he turns off
the lights you saw the way he was tapping the top
top part he knows every inch of his home he knows
where everything is it's not pulling me out as and
I'm like that's so unrealistic it it just made me
question is this another body that I'm unaware of
and maybe I'm harping on semantics because it's
probably just money and I'm probably overthinking
it but it did make me think like wait what is
happening here cuz then there was that other
moment too where he ends up next to a body um
and I was like is that her body that fell or what
because of how dark it was I I think that that on
purpose well they had blurry things bodies going
around I did I think they wanted us to be in the
dark a little bit figuratively right I'm going
to assume it was money because again we didn't
see many other bodies in that downstairs where
that that woman was being uh held captive so and
again aside from you know having self-defense and
his home and I mean money really did deserve what
happened to him he was holding the gun right at
the guy's head after he they had uh you know tried
robbing him so you know aside from that like he
didn't seem like and and again aside from also his
flawed and misguided thing of what he was doing
to that poor woman uh as well but we didn't know
that at this time right right right I'm just I'm
just just generally speaking after the fact I I
I I don't think he was an evil human being besides
that in general like I'm going to go out and start
just murdering people so I I I think that was I'm
pretty sure whoa whoa you didn't think he was evil
no no no I said aside from he was doing to that
to that poor girl like that was I I just mean in
generality like I don't think I he was targeted I
I think he was e as evil comes but he was targeted
in being evil in terms of he doesn't seem like
a mass murderer yeah that's what I mean he's not
going out like hey Just for kicks I'm just going
to start like killing people you know what I mean
liketh felt like he had a bad hand dealt to him
in terms of his daughter he's uh Hey the world
owes me so I'm ow a kid now I'm going to take it
out now on this woman who took my child going to
get a child of her I guess I'm I'm going to let
her go now and now these people are coming into
my home they're stealing from me uh self-defense
trespassing in my territory like I I just mean
like he's not like when we're asking is that money
is that someone else I just don't think he's going
out getting other bodies and that's someone else
I think that was money but again it's so tly it's
the with how the lighting was it was hard to tell
but I'm pretty sure I agree with you that it was
money but I do think also flawed logic doesn't
just happen after you deal with grief right
like when you're dealing with grief you become
one of two things better or bitter he clearly
became bitter and that's what caused all of this
to happen but that was a seed that was obviously
already inside him I don't think he lived this
like beautiful perfect life and he was an amazing
father and never did he harm anybody and then
the day his daughter died he was like actually
I'm going to kidnap this girl that got off and I'm
going to put her in my basement and then I'm going
to inseminate her and then make her have my kid
and let her go like I think he probably already
was super duper flawed and which makes me think
he already might have been um doing some form of
kidnapping tortur something I don't who's to say
that's not the point of this movie but I I don't
think you know what do they say trauma explains
Behavior it doesn't excuse it so I do think this
they did explain it here but I don't think that
this is like a brand knew before this he was
standup Citizen and to your point too he was an
Army veteran he had you know probably who knows
the PTSD was going through and he was visually
impaired from being a veteran too so I mean he
could have just been like you know just gone off
the deep end even before his daughter just from
that alone I mean or not I guess it's yeah one one
way or the other but I do I think that he was such
perfect casting for this the acting from Steven
Lang and also too uh not sure what that actress's
name uh was it was it Rocky or Roxy it was Rocky
Rocky okay but they they at the end I saw and I
recognized her name she is is so she was fantastic
she is so good uh oh my gosh I think everything
your eyes are so essential especially in a movie
where there's not as much dialogue because it's
called Don't breathe which implies not speaking
it everything was in her eyes but also she's maybe
my least favorite character in the whole movie
because like you did this to us babes you were
like I need this money and then you had every
opportunity to get saved but you just still
wanted the money you killed your boyfriend you
killed your best friend cuz you wanted the money
to get out of a situation that sucked but like
oh my God you crazy it's like kind of not nice
that she gets to live her life now I agree with
you and I disagreed with what she was doing but
it was a good thing they did show us the situation
she was dealing with and also we got a little into
her backstory through the dialogue and Exposition
so we could sympathize with her even though it was
very illogical what she was doing and not smart uh
and obviously it cost money and Alex their lives
due to her poor decision making so that was her
little sister not her daughter right I believe
that was her little sister yeah yeah I mean I
sister stuff pulls on my heartstrings as a big
sis I would do anything for my little sister to
get her out but this doesn't this goes past the
point of anything like you can't just there's
other ways there are better ways to make money
like you just can't and and from the start and
I love that this movie did this when we're stuck
in the closet and they could leave but in instead
she memorizes the code and she does the code then
like four more times when uh she goes through the
vent and and she's like no no we got to get out
of here with the money then when she finally is
when they're finally almost at the door and he's
like you have to choose is it the money or him
getting arrested and she chooses the money again
just I think this this movie had a lot of strong
messages and it's like what matters to you the
most because sometimes you get to prioritized
things and sometimes you only get one thing and
what is is it wow yeah that was they killed this
yeah no like I said very suspenseful terrifying uh
film and again Stephen Lang I mean you already
said that there wasn't a lot of exposition but
he literally had two scenes of dialogue in this
entire film he had the one where he says to uh
money how many other people are there with you
and then he had that other scene uh with Rocky
where he was just explaining like uh you know what
had happened with him uh and I believe that was
it I mean but masterful performances from all
uh really scene at the the one scene where he
has her uh that's what you're talking about when
he explains yeah yeah that that whole scene yeah
um but also need a name for the scene yeah right
I lik what you were was saying earlier but uh I
will say this for a film that's an hour and 25
27 minutes whatever it was like it felt longer
than that just because of the ride we were on like
you know I completely agree with you so funny but
I I remember one time looking down to see how
long it been because I was thinking to myself
it feel like I've been here for 2 hours I don't
mean that as a knock on the movie agreed I just
honestly felt like I don't know how much longer
I can take this yes that's that's how I meant it
too when it's not a knock on pacing or anything I
actually thought it was past well and it ended up
like at the appropriate time as well but I'm like
it feels so much longer than it is not in a bad
way so totally agree with you there this movie
kind of drove me insane like genuinely while
we are watching it all the predicting and all of
the wondering and all of the like squeaks in the
floor and button pushes and the dog being there I
felt trapped I felt like I could not breathe it's
obviously the title for a reason in the movie
but I feel like it was a message to us like I
I should have paid more attention going in that
this was going to be so effing scary yeah no for
sure I hope this film makes people think again if
they want to steal from a blind person if you want
to steal from anybody yeah well especially a blind
person who's an army vet and has lost a child yeah
cuz they thought this was going to be easy what
was it you said when they were going in you were
like they're going to think this is going to be
5 10 minutes and it is not yeah that's why they
they put that thing in the for the dog to eat and
they're like this is going to be a 10-minute job
and that's it simple easy what did you feel
about the very small amount of characters I
actually liked that I mean we didn't need because
we're it's literally 95% of the film is set in one
location which I thought was good that that added
to the claustrophobia feel to the film yeah so I
mean we didn't really need more characters than
we had we had the three uh character the thieves
and then you have Steven Lang's character and then
you have the little sister I mean I I mean I felt
that was actually appropriate to have especially
if you're going to be at one location like that
throughout the whole film I was completely fine
how' you feel about it I really liked it too I
did keep wondering if Alex's dad was going to play
a part because they had taken the keys and kind of
dropped that seed and I was wondering you know is
he going to notice is he going to save the day but
other than that I really felt like there was a it
was a perfect amount and usually a movie like this
it feels really small budget if there's so few
characters but in this it was just it was kind
of like a bottle movie I mean we're in the house
almost the entire time I love movies like this
I watched on this channel I watched hush before
did you see that I have not seen hush oh it was
so good also um home invasion movies really freak
me the F out but typically we start in the home in
those movies right and we're trying to fend off
but in this one we were they were asking us to
root for people breaking into a house uh at least
for them in some sense and so that's why I feel
like this was a really fresh take on a category
that's already been so so overdone in the horror
space yeah well I mean I was rooing for Rocky to
get out of that lifestyle especially from that
one guy who's got that disgusting tattoo and just
that broken down home style that she was in but
if you put as much effort into your thievery into
another job you probably just make a lot of money
anyways just say you were rooting for her I was
rooting for was no no I was rooting well yeah I
actually liked Alex like he was like let's get out
of here let's not do this like I mean he actually
had a very uh you know sense of uh like logicality
so uh him I actually like he could have hit the
button at any time I know but he he was he was
just really drawn to Rocky and he just that just
wavered over uh you know any smart decision making
he wanted to do not to everyone out there it's
beautiful to be in love but when it's unrequited
love and she's with somebody else you just can't
put both your lives on the line stay in the friend
zone just uh make the smart decision yeah uh what
did you think about the lighting stuff I know that
you a couple times are like it's really dark it it
actually play yeah because he's visually impaired
it almost gives us a view into what he can and
can't see literally so I like it too because like
when they can't see they're in his world literally
like it's his house but it's also his world
because only he even though he can't see like he
know he can hear everything but they can't see as
well so it's like even the playing field it really
was I loved it actually um but I I was fine with
it I mean there's a lot there's films that have
been criticized uh for bad lighting like alien
verse Predator requium I don't know if you've
ever seen that but it's I haven't seen it but I
know it's got like one of the worst uh lighting
of any films like in movie history worst isn't
poorly done or super dark both both okay yeah I
didn't think this was poorly done no no no it was
again I just for the style they were going for and
then with Steven character I actually appreciated
it personally yeah there were a few times like
what's happening what and then like as we got the
reveal that his character couldn't really see it
was like okay now I understand what they're going
for and then like the silhouette shots it just
added to the terror and the suspense too and there
was something you said a couple of times that I
was already thinking like when characters were not
this isn't even a lit thing but where characters
were reaching fingers through them like what's
going on on the other side my mind's playing
tricks now and what's about to happen but we did
actually get revealed shots because like when they
were when they finally got out from the under the
uh the cellar like he was always waiting on the
other side because again it's his world it's his
domain he knows every place to go in that in that
in that home of his so what do you think about the
fact that there's a don't breathe too oh there is
a don't breathe too there's a I'm only asking you
that because this feels so Standalone but we here
at the end of this movie that he made it and he's
in the hospital I was going to say that too I know
he's an army fan how did he all that I know he's
built like a truck um I mean I really enjoyed this
one so I'm curious what the storyline would be for
that I mean because he I mean everything was built
upon like in his home and domain so I don't know
if I see him going after that uh Rocky and all
that I feel like her story is done I don't know
like what you would do for the second one but I
mean if you guys are interested in seeing Roxy
and myself react to that one i' I'd be I'd be
down for some me being being a [__] jump scares
again I'm sorry I'm Pur you're so rude of me no no
no you're good um but I'm a [__] all the time
no it's it's all but in regards to storyline I I
mean I my only assumption is he wants to have a
kid again a child I other than that I don't know
where what else he would do storyline wise what
would you think of I'm curious about it yeah the
only the way they leave it I don't know I think
that it could start with Rocky being like I took
this money hand giving herself in or whatever but
I'm not sure she's in it I don't know I really
don't know but you took the words out of my mouth
before with if you guys want us to watch it then
like this video comment let us know if you want us
to do don't breathe too what did you think about
this movie were you watching it for the first time
along with us and were you holding your breath the
whole time like us did I steal your to ask nope
it was I feel like I uh it was an assist okay
and a layup it was a dunk Laker fan to Celtic FL
fan it was one two punch it was a uh who are CU I
don't know I was going to say thelman Louise
but we're not thma and Louise it was a a one
and two who are two people that what's a buddy
cop girl guy thing buddy cop uh Rigs and mertop
but that's not a guy girl uh I don't know Scully
and Moulder there you oh that's a good one I like
that let go let us know thanks so much reject you
guys rock and we will see you maybe for don't bre
two m